[Music]
zip that sup action in city cleansing
news cleanse the city please cleanse it
well submitted by a dog and his ball
priests air bombed a Russian city with
holy water oh that's good that's good
yeah because Russia is corrupt they need
to spray that [ __ ] all over so that
there are these priests in this Russian
city of toover and this was the first
time ever it so every single year they
end up having like a massive like prayer
gathering to like pray for this is a
cello pray cello I like that hashtag yes
so they're saying that it's a real
massive no so that priests have been
flying over to ver on sobriety date
because it's like this very day it's a
real massive cuz its mass you're reading
while you're listening and process
things that seems like it anyway
okay so there's this the date this day
called sobriety date every year since
2006 they've been flying over and
praying that's what they've been doing
yeah it's like trying to cleanse the
city from drinking and fornication but
there's too many demons so they gotta
just holy water this time so this time
was the first time that they decided to
dump my picture the gallons of holy
water I picture that you know the
[ __ ] crop duster [ __ ] like the
farmers used to [ __ ] put the
pesticides on yeah they didn't go over
the sea Jets that means hi oh my god
imagine they don't even do that it's
just a guy from a helicopter with the
thing and he's just do you want to find
out how cool
like it okay you're gonna like how are
they doing it how they doing it oh it is
only water they put it in 17 or 7 nice
beautiful plane is blessed the pilot
should be imagine being this insane
that's so innocent and fun you actually
think this water is [ __ ] cure in a
city
what is the brain on its D I love this
yeah they made the water yeah I know
right yeah put it in water balloons
start [ __ ] hitting people with it
yeah it's gonna hit like a pigeon and
that pigeons gonna be holy
yes what kind of religion do they play
Orthodox Christianity Orthodox that's
the other cap against uh well they're
not against but there's Catholicism and
there's Orthodox Christianity what's the
difference between that and like regular
Christianity I don't know oh you mean
we're in American Christianity yeah
American Christianity is like a
descendant of the what do you call it
the British one
when you know King Henry he he changed
to become Protestant yeah and then so
all the Protestants that were also and
then I guess there's other religious
Christians that came to America that
were not really allowed in Europe yeah
and then from there they created their
own [ __ ] so American Christianity is
just its own thing
how come they're they got such
ceremonial garb anytime it's it's off
the dock for the docks it's funny
clothes everywhere yeah it's super funny
anytime you see somebody in funny
clothes they're Orthodox whatever or
yeah like Orthodox Jews you see those
cats when wool yeah the middle of summer
and they have the curly sideburns yep
yep so they were saying that Eastern
Orthodox Church so they dumped 18.7
leaders oh no wait sorry well I want it
that take 70 liters no it's about 18
gallons damn for anything
that was like a long here's a lotta a
lot of area they have to cover a lot
yeah man they should have got the
[ __ ] pesticide machine you know it
had just missed it the whole city
mystify yeah what if what if the
military took that as an act of
terrorism just shot the plane down
because act of terrorism they bomb here
if someone was throwing liquids out of a
plane would we consider that after
terrorism when 9/11 happened my biology
teacher said wouldn't it be sick if
instead of bombing them we bombed them
with bread and I was like that's the
stupidest [ __ ] I ever heard Fred went
bring food and [ __ ] yeah killing wants
the kindness but they don't always like
pita bread I was like hey what a great
idea then anytime they want to eat those
just [ __ ] bomb us again and she's
like oh yeah I mean that's what North
Korea does every time they want food
they just threaten to raise hell yeah
like all the neighboring countries and
then that's when they get foreign aid
Snickers commercial I need to get away
you know you're hungry
yep true good old Russia I'm glad that
they're trying to like solve their
problems with holy water
yeah how about therapy instead yeah what
is the problem too many people [ __ ]
too many people drinking too many people
drinking it's like I guess it's like
they're Lent or some [ __ ] right sobriety
damn righty day well I mean that vodka
keeps them warm and it's Tuesday
September 11 oh really
they fly a plane and a bomb oh my god
well they're gay has a different
significance from ours I think every
single culture has like a drinking thing
though right
like a non drinking day like like I know
the Irish have Saint Patty's Day and and
they don't drink on that day no they do
they drink oh boy do we have four did
you guys yeah [ __ ] yeah fourth of July
Memorial Day super for me yep
Thanksgiving Christmas Day
eggnog on Christmas New Year's
like the most three March Madness is a
whole month of drinking but Halloween
dude I never not drank on Halloween
going back to like [ __ ] me 18 years
old in my life
I heard they drank more alcohol than
they did water in your back in a day
because of the source like it was like
it was too dirty but then their alcohol
level was really low so so everyone
drank making sure that water won't be
bad but curfew I was in the store
yesterday at Target and they already had
a Halloween on the Halloween [ __ ] up and
I was like I [ __ ] love it
actually me too I love it I like you
when they bring in the festivities
[ __ ] me how come you're coming in hard
like someone's on you no no no my wife
loves to give everyone hell about how
they do it too early but I enjoy it I'm
embracing October no it's September I
know but I mean it's pretty much over no
cuz I heard this there's nothing that
goes on in September no that's why I
like it coming in early because I was at
bonds and then I was always to smell I
smell pumpkin and cinnamon and then the
lady the Cassiar lady was like yeah
they're brain and all the Halloween's
that Friday cuz it was in August and
that's gone well no I like it
me too I've been bracing the [ __ ] now
[ __ ] these people I would say last year
I would get upset about it but for some
reason this year awesome Halloween [ __ ]
maybe that's it that's it but like even
when I go to the back of stores I can
already see like the Christmas stuff
getting ready I'm like is that a [ __ ]
tree I'm like hell yeah bring it on I'm
bringing it
that's what I say bring on the Christmas
what's good I mean cuz after July right
what is there really obvious in
September it's like the most boring
month what do they do
Beach time basically back to school
month yeah back to schools like three
months I swear to God every one in
September birthdays are like August is
one of those months I had that a guy was
like I want it to be my month his name
was Augustus and he says this is my
[ __ ] month ho and then he changed the
whole entire calendar just for him oh
I'm glad the hoes listen to her no wait
where'd they get the other name it was
probably something else and then they're
like I'm [ __ ] mr. Caesar Augustus
Julius Caesar did the same thing that's
like okay that's why October's two
months off cuz October is it means eight
octo yeah but it's in the tenth month
because they got moved they pushed it
yeah so I guess so Augustus move there
once and then Julius moved it once
that's why everything all these [ __ ]
are trying to make it and we still keep
it I know that's all hard and strong
they're dictatorships were not to
mention religious man it's it's only
2019 right now because of [ __ ]
religion why cuz of the like before
Christ after Christ yeah yeah it's not
like it's actually the year 2019 so when
does that really start when Jesus was
born or when Jesus died it's after Jesus
died everything is after Jesus what if
we start dating stuff the what it's
supposed to be so like like five million
fifty four fifty four billion be such a
pain in the ass
it's September fifty four billion yeah
that's tight it's tight because we
should get the earth a little bit of
credit I think five four three billion
years old almost all right Yvette yeah
albedo on my checks on everything four
point five six billions for now we'll
just stick to the Christian one because
of Jesus its wages anyway yeah so they
were saying here about Russia and
drinking that in December 2016
seventy-four people died in a Siberian
city because they were drinking scented
bath lotion mislabeled as containing
drinkable ethanol but the ingredient was
actually methanol which is they still
drank it yeah because hardcore
[ __ ] [ __ ] rush oh man cuz
they're saying that right now like some
independent experts say that independent
experts good guys I'd like to study
really hard on their own but no one
credits them for [ __ ] that's an
independent expert yeah yeah that's a
lot of [ __ ] in the comment section
you know that for sure people that read
Wikipedia very thoroughly you know we're
all independent experts and you know
people they get like the top comments or
the most thumbs up in a comment section
that's independent X on my independent
expert bro know so they're saying that
Russian Russia per capita alcohol
consumption went from eighteen point
seven liters of pure alcohol 2005 to
eleven point seven liters in 2016 but
these independent experts are saying
that those numbers can't be fully
trusted because they don't account for
bootleg moonshine or
Russians who drink non beverage alcohol
like bathroom products or cologne or
lighter fluid these hardcore Fox man you
know I just instantly saw this statistic
of South Koreans consume like three
times more alcohol than Russians and and
there's just like a worldwide like
census on how much each country consumes
alcohol and they do it through purchases
and all that yeah
South Korea is like insane hi why don't
they get the flack for what like the bad
rep yeah nobody calls them drunks and
[ __ ] maybe cuz they don't act stupid on
alcohol I've seen Koreans and that
[ __ ] dumb go to k-town yeah but in
Korea you know I think they just they
drink a lot but I couldn't tell like
they weren't fighting on the streets and
I can crazy true I've seen everybody in
every culture do that [ __ ] yeah alcohol
makes it Boulder pretty stupid yeah same
result just read her faces yep
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]